Harry Styles kicked off the evening with a heartfelt performance of "Watermelon Sugar,"...
...followed by Billie Eilish with her hit "Everything I Wanted."
Megan Thee Stallion won the first award of the night for Best New Artist.
Taylor Swift won Album of the Year for "Folklore."
Beyonce's win for Best R&B Performance marked her 28th Grammy,...
...making her the most decorated woman in Grammy history.
Because of the pandemic, there was no live audience.
Instead, artists performed for each other.
Dua Lipa teamed up with rapper DaBaby.
And for the first time, Anderson .Paak and Bruno Mars performed together "Silk Sonic."
There were also other firsts.
Employees from hard-hit music venues across the nation presented awards.
"Wild Card," Miranda Lambert.
H.E.R. won Song of the Year for "I Can't Breathe,"...
...beating Beyonce, Taylor Swift and Billie Eilish.
And recognition was given to the women of country music....
...who dominated the Best Country Album category.
And artists paid tribute to musicians lost in 2020.